yesterday we said goodbye to Bruce and
hello to Caitlyn Jenner Vanity Fair
released its July cover of Caitlyn just
yesterday and the response has been
nothing short of explosive I want you to
just check out these statistics 12
million people have watched the
behind-the-scenes video of her
photoshoot vanityfair.com has reached
record traffic with more than 8 million
unique visitors and on social media
Vanity Fair trended number 1 on both
Twitter and Facebook right after the
cover was released Caitlyn Jenner's new
twitter handle has now almost 12 million
followers even the president tweeted at
her Chris Mitchell is the publisher and
chief revenue officer of Vanity Fair big
day big week congratulations what does
this mean from a business perspective
because people don't think of Vanity
Fair in terms of social media or digital
at all well we think of Vanity Fair in
terms of digital social media and I
think this is part of a continuing story
of two things I'd say number one
obviously Vanity Fair is breaking news
and is at the center of those big
cultural moments you know last month to
put that number some of those numbers
you gave us in perspective last month we
had our biggest single day of traffic on
the website and that was the release of
the Star Wars portfolio also shot by
Annie that did one and a half million
visitors this did as you said eight so
you know the numbers here are just so
beyond anything we've ever seen the
other interesting stat is when Kim
Kardashian tweeted or hashtag that she
broke the Internet it took us two hours
to surpass the number of tweets that
that famous covered that she did with
the champagne glass so this is just
beyond anything any of us have seen from
a money standpoint ya know how do you
how that's what we really want to know
how it oh kanha ties yeah how do you
make money off of so the trend is you
know the digital newsstand replaces the
vert the real newsstand you know and
what this allows us to do is two things
we've had for the first time an
innovative pay wall so that we were
sending people to vanityfair.com to go
and buy both the issue or subscribe
digitally to the magazine if you do that
you go to Vanity Fair now in fact you
can get the entire article one week in
advance of the magazine hitting the
newsstand this is the first time we've
ever taken a cover and released it a
full week in advance so that people can
get the store
a online first before they get the the
magazine that allows us to make money
that way it also allows us to sort serve
the you know huge volume of impressions
we have to the advertisers on the site
both the video impressions and the
advertisers who are buying around this
story itself and that's that's new will
we ever get to a point Chris where the
advertisers can choose to advertise in
the printed edition of the magazine
after everybody knows what the cover is
so for example I don't know whether this
is possible probably not enough runway
left before the magazine actually lands
on my doorstep but if if the advertiser
knew the Caitlyn Jenner was on the cover
wouldn't the advertiser want to be part
of that printed edition is it hard not
to tell them when you're trying to sell
at it's an interesting part of our
conundrum is that we keep the cover
subject under wrap and we we sell the
advertising now obviously we have
certain issues like our Hollywood Issue
so advertising the no dance no no it's
coming out and we see a huge spike in
the number of ads that we get in those
in those themed issues you know it's a
little more difficult when you're doing
it around news events like this because
you know there are advertisers who of
course would love to embrace the the
topicality and of course now we've seen
how well it's been received the magazine
is in fact a nutrient jerk it was going
to be well-received well because of the
nature of this you know we're seeing
just an amazing and we knew they think
after the Diane Sawyer interview because
this was well planned when that
interview happened and after that we saw
such an amazing outpouring of support
from the LGBT community as well as from
the greater you know population as a
whole so that was I think our first
indication that this was just going to
be not just a huge traffic driver but
just a really sort of well warm welcome
for for Caitlyn about six months ago I
had a chance to sit down with Graydon
Carter and we talked about sort of this
digital revolution and what it means to
VF let's take a look we're kind of bless
we're monthly magazine so we're not
competing with the Internet Bureau
weekly or daily I think it's it's
rougher
and you know my goal is that if there's
one magazine left on this earth I gotta
make a Vanity Fair and the fact is we do
something that you really get on the
internet we tell great stories and
they're in the hands of great writers
and we team those up with great
photographs in true Vanity Fair style
you're not competing with the internet
you just want it so what is the strategy
after this in terms of how do you
maintain you have eight million unique
views yesterday how do you keep this
party going well I think the reality is
we're not gonna maintain that same spike
of traveling yes you know there will
always be these sort of great gold rush
spikes you know and I think Graydon is
is you know the best editor in this
business because he knows how to sort of
capture restored he knows how to find
that scoop you know this is just another
in a tradition we've had you know think
of the release of the first photos of
Suri Cruise you know these are these
great moments in Graydon has made it the
mission of vanity fair to be at the
center of it so that's naturally in this
day and age a digital story and then you
can sort of commemorate that or
memorialize that with the the there's a
reason Caitlyn chose vanity fair because
he wanted this to live on as he said you
with them as a magazine so to your point
she yes yes you're right and then anyhow
jenner/kardashian clan knows a few
things about making money yeah and maybe
even a little media manipulation on top
of that who's exploiting who here oh I
think that's a great question and i know
i think great and cover that well in the
times this morning you know everything
is a campaign you know movie releases
presidential campaigns everything is a
coordinated campaign and we are you know
willingly and admittedly complicit in
that you know that is part of of the
nature of what we do we are capitalizing
on this amazing news event and Caitlyn
is capitalizing on her ability to roll
out a Twitter account and this this
cover story and obviously what she's
going to be doing in reality television
and many other things you know both
for-profit and I'm sure for her own so
you're both exploding each other equally
I think this and there's a day what is a
capitalist and commercial business and
and we are thrilled that we can you know
monetize this even better now because
the digital resources then we could when
we just had a magazine so it's a great
new
forward as a business as a media
business this is the way we want to we
want to live we want to have a dynamic
robust thick magazine and we want to
have these amazing moments online where
we can monetize there's no question if
you can do this every month that is
everyone will be in great shape
congratulations thank you so much yes
yes random chair and for Caitlyn Jenner
that is Chris Mitchell he's Vanity
Fair's publisher and chief revenue
officer